where are you right now I'm on number
eight at Bulls way where is that in
South Carolina yes my home course is
okay okay so you play a lot of golf and
then you started a new monthly Sirius XM
show called on par with Darius Rucker
right here okay and you debuted it
yesterday if I said you could give up
your music career and you could play on
the Senior Tour no you could be really
good on the Senior Tour oh please now
you're now you're yes now if I could
just play like wait $15 a week come out
but you know if I could be great like
win wages and stuff I have to think
about that one but what you're going to
do is you're going to chat with
celebrities and pro golfers yeah you
know and talk about the game but talk
also about you know life and music and
movies and and and you know you see
those guys out there hitting with
headphones on you know I want to know
what what time you listening to what you
are getting with iTunes on and stuff
like that but you know also talk about
the game because we all love the game so
much in and it's just really this is our
month of talking golf all right so it's
a new monthly Sirius XM show called on
par with Darius Rucker debuted yesterday
from 3:00 to 4:00 Eastern on Sirius XM
PGA Tour radio and Sirius XM app are you
having more fun music wise now than you
did with hooting the Blowfish uh it's
just a different time it's more fun now
because uh I remember it at all you know
it's a lot clearer and how young were
you when you guys first exploded so that
was what 94 94 I was I think I turned to
I just turned 28 okay on that app oh
yeah if you were 22
like can you understand what happens to
these kids that are really young and had
that success and if I was 22 I probably
wouldn't be alive today yeah it would
have been a totally different animal and
it was audio a big animal but if 22 man
I was crazy a tweety - were you crazy -
28 yeah but not as crazy as a lotta
crazy
you didn't have any money at 22 exactly
that's exact
didn't have any money goodbye yeah you
know it was it was we were just in the
middle of for us we didn't even think
that life had changed we just in the
middle of the party the shows were
getting bigger the digital and somebody
was something's driving us around on the
bus that was pretty cool the difference
though with the country audience and a
pop audience and maybe I'm not being
fair to you with what hooting the
Blowfish who they played to but more of
maine's mainstream radio pop radio as
opposed to country what's the difference
the big distance is the loyalty is
amazing like once what country fans are
amazingly loyal and like pop music
they're always looking for the next big
thing and always and they're always
looking you know I bring my big thing
about that is like when we were playing
when hoodoos playing I didn't know
anybody at radio because nobody radio
wanted to know you because they knew
chances are they weren't going to play
your back single you know so they didn't
want to get to know you and then country
music I know everybody at every radio
station then and it's really the loyalty
and you know if you're playing are you
making good music they'll want to listen
who do you want to play with performer
McCartney McCartney his number one on my
bucket list of people that I would love
to play with what would you cover with
McCartney maybe on the maze maybe
probably I may do that I saw him the
other day for the first time and it was
just mind-blowing the amazing so yeah
you know he killed it I thought
something I love this thing baby I'm a
minute ago well of LDLs okay but do you
walk up to him yeah did you say anything
to him yes I thank him for influencing
me and thank them for being my favorite
horse of all time we talked for a minute
and my kids were freaking out because
they're big Beatles fans but uh yeah
talk to him a little bit did he know who
you were
yes yes I should lie on the shul I think
it is manageable and you're probably the
only guy who ever said to McCartney
thanks for inspiring me yeah we really
only got now now you understand when you
have your meet and greets at your
concert when somebody comes up and says
hey you know what your music meant to me
you were that guy who comes up where you
going own gun did you hear when that guy
said exactly and you know he just and he
just found out who I was five seconds
where I walked up to it but yeah that
was that was cool did you ask for a
picture oh we took a picture yeah we
doesn't took a picture you know I have
to take a picture APIs tricking Paul
McCartney man I had to take a picture
was there somebody there to take the
picture yes they had bad their people
okay and then yeah yeah so we're managed
by the same management group so it was a
you know they hooked me up pretty good
all right the ideal guest that you want
on your show your golf show is to my god
ah Jack I'd love to get Jack Nicklaus on
there and and just talk golf and talk
life for a second I bet you plated
Tigers wedding is there any well I don't
know get tiger on oh you do you know
yeah he's my boy wasn't gonna come over
for me absolutely could you remember
your tiger should you be tiger right now
and go
it was away his butt no no that's
actually a boy because I'm like me right
now clearly I am i what was that like
though when you down did you how many
songs did you perform at Tigers wedding
oh I don't know let me show you did a
whole show we literally we did off show
man
yeah how nervous nervous a lot nervous
dolls too drunk did he did he play did
he come onstage yes he did he was awful
swinger and he I'll tell that to his
face he's an awful singer but he came on
and you know tried to do some stuff but
it was it was funny it was funny
will you play his next wedding oh he
keeps telling me he hates country music
so pie but but his his story is a
country music song now hold that for
sure that's really it's definitely
country's ago but uh you know I don't
think I'll be there but I'll be real
athlete's foot okay what is the one
topic that you can't go to in a country
song
it feels like as long as you can go to
like you can write about your dog your
truck or your wife left here is love
I guess anti-american or anti-american
can't really yeah you can't be at that
American in country music at all you
know you mean yeah yeah politics for me
especially oh yeah there's some guys
that that do it but not a lot of guys to
single pauses in countries yeah that's
probably what I meant I don't think
anti-american would go over in any genre
so that yeah I don't think rap that go
and rap either but what do I know
yeah but you can rap though I'm a rapper
no no you're nothing I can't do good
luck with the show
sorry to interrupt around its Sirius XM
yeah seconds you're gonna come on the
show for me right oh really
I will punch you mean all those free
tickets you gave me and all the stuff
you did for me and you performed it my
50th birthday party and then you went to
my 60th birthday party at Pebble Beach
and now you want me to do something for
you yeah just you know just up five
minutes ago such as me five minutes of
your five minutes all right yes
all right don't see what I can do let's
see what I thank you very much hi hi
baby
those various Rucker country music star
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience